this week on brian ross investigates
reckless or resilient the president says
he's learned a lot after getting
kovit 19. i learned a lot about kovit
i learned it by really going to school
this is the real school
but are americans getting the truth
about the president's health
what will this mean for the race for a
vaccine we're joined by one of the
country's leading experts on infectious
disease
dr william shafter with the election
only a month away now
will your vote get counted what are the
russians up to
russia continues to try to influence our
elections
the former head of national security at
the department of justice
will give us the latest their goal is to
turn americans
against americans and this week's
winners and losers in the media
covering the cover-up at the white house
when dr connolly
lies on saturday and then gleefully
admits to lying on sunday
you know that politics has taken
precedence
from the law and crime trial network
this is brian ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined tonight by my
colleague at law and crime rhonda
schwartz
and rhonda we're one month away from
what will be a very consequential
election
with growing concerns already that this
essential piece of democracy
could somehow be compromised rhonda
that's right brian intelligence
officials have warned
they've already detected signs of
election interference
from russia and other countries and both
political
parties are gearing up to contest the
results
and rhonda the head of the fbi chris
wray has repeatedly
warned that there are serious efforts
underway by the russians
only to be contradicted by his boss the
president
of the united states our biggest threat
to this election
is governors from opposing parties
controlling ballots
millions of ballots to me that's a much
bigger threat than foreign countries
because much of the stuff coming out
about foreign countries turned out to be
untrue
but we certainly have seen very active
very active
efforts by the russians to influence our
election in 2020
and and i think the intelligence
community has
assessed this publicly to primarily to
denigrate vice president biden
to get a better understanding of all
this we're now joined by john carlin the
former head of the national security
division at the department of justice
and john it was just four years ago that
you were watching as the russians began
to try to meddle in our elections
that's right brian and unfortunately as
we saw in in 2018
and now again in 2020 it's more of the
same
what do you think they can do in
addition to putting out
essentially fake items on social media
can they also mess with the structure of
the elections themselves
well think about the structure in a
couple different categories so one would
be
could they affect actual vote counts and
in all disclosure i was just involved
with a
pro bono suit in georgia the judge ruled
in our favor
that forces the state of georgia to use
paper backup ballots and so if you're
using
paper backup ballots then even if a bad
actor like russia
tried to mess with with the vote count
you could go look at the paper
there's something physical to look at at
the end of the day and so you could
assure people
that it was a fair vote so i think
that's less likely
the other area that they could do some
type of mischief would be with voter
registration
that may make it more difficult on the
day of voting to determine whether
someone's properly registered to vote
it could ultimately be worked out but
it's something to be concerned about
the third thing that is quite easy for
them to do
along with other not just russia but
other nation states and even some
criminal groups would be
to mislead people about where and how to
vote
and that's something we need to take
very seriously and i think you've seen
companies like facebook twitter others
try to roll out the correct
information for voters from what you
know is the u.s prepared to defend
against that kind of thing
this time around look uh
there's more that could be done but i'm
glad that private companies are
stepping in to try to assist on the one
hand
on the other hand i really wish that was
government and we didn't need private
companies to be stepping in uh
to provide this right type of assistance
but for all your viewers out there
you can play a part too i mean to the
extent you
go find this information about the
proper ways in which one can vote
and spread it to your community to
to make sure that's the the antidote the
to
the misinformation is to get the true
information out to people that trust you
there have been reports john that last
time around the russians were able to
essentially
plant malware in the election
commissions of two
florida counties never used it
apparently but planted it
how would you detect that kind of thing
if it hasn't been used and it's only
there standing by to be triggered
on election day well look there
russia is quite a capable cyber actor
and i think there are
uh even for russia and even for now red
lines that they haven't crossed
in in the past and the reason they don't
cross them isn't because they're nice
under putin's russia it's because
they're worried about the type of
retaliation that might occur
from the united states we i wish our
leaders were doing
a better job including the very top the
president
at sending that message of deterrence
don't mess with us
free and fair elections are important to
americans and if you do there are going
to be consequences
in the absence of that there's great
work that cyber forensic firms can do
that homeland security can assist with
and that funding is gone to state and
locals
so you can detect anomalies if they
occur on your system
when you ran the national security
division you had a close-up look at the
activities of foreign actors foreign
states
in trying to meddle with the elections
and you say it's not just russia
that's correct it's not it's not just
russia and what
particularly now in the misinformation
game i think we need to be concerned
about
iran north korea in the past
china has been less active but in terms
of
causing changes or disrupting vote but
has been quite active
in collecting information about the
campaigns
and the other threat we need to be
concerned about now is
not one that's intentionally messing
with our election but could
inadvertently mess with it and that's
ransomware these are criminal groups
that deploy malware that locks up
systems so nobody can use them
until you pay them money it is exploding
we have never seen
ransomware occurring at the rate at
which it's occurring now
and it's hitting everyone it's hitting
hospitals it's hit local police
departments it's his schools and it's
hitting company after company
that have been trying to assist and so
one of the things we've been trying to
do
is to reach out to state and local
officials so that in the event that they
get hit by ransomware
it doesn't interfere with their ability
to conduct a proper vote count or open a
poll in place
we're four weeks away now from the
election what are your greatest fears
and concerns
of what could happen
the area i'm most concerned about
actually is
is more to do with our trust and
confidence in
the result there's probably going to be
a period of time and certainly in some
states
where the votes not counted i expect
nation states to jump into that breach
russia in particular
and put out as much misinformation as
they can because their goal is to turn
americans
against americans they're fundamentally
under putin he views democracy as an
existential threat and he wants to make
us doubt the democratic
system that's why it's so important for
people in both parties
republican democrat now to send the
message
that we need to be patient during that
time period
that we can ultimately because there are
paper ballots reach the right
results free of digital interference and
to
work with the media to get them not to
hype
what are going to be endless
misinformation stories and of course
the president of the united states
should take responsibility as well
to call on that calm and defend our
democracy
we haven't seen that that must be very
disappointing to you you worked for
barack obama
uh and the word went out then what do
you think is going to happen now
well brockman was my third president
that i worked for as a as a career
official and i don't think this
should have anything to do with party uh
this is about
the integrity of the american democratic
system and that's something we all share
regardless of what our partisan views
may be so i hope that the president and
you've certainly seen every other
government official doing it
to send them the message uh to folks
that we can have free
and fair elections and also to
counteract when you see
deliberate russian misinformation
campaigns as both facebook
and twitter along with other social
media have identified
and if you had your own job now as head
of the national security division
at the department of justice what would
you be doing now that you don't think is
being done
well i'm not sure that the tip of that
spear would be from the justice
department national security division
what i hope they're doing
is looking to discover
the type of schemes using the tools that
they have that russia and others
are employing and then making them
public and sharing it with the american
people
so that we are not fooled the department
of homeland security i think has been
trying to do
uh a good job of reaching out to state
and locals to
provide them the tools that they need
whether it's help from
if they're willing to accept it from
those who can detect malware
to working through with them how to how
to
counteract this type of disinformation
or misinformation if they see it
all right john carlin thank you very
much for joining us tonight fascinating
insights
thank you ben coming up the president
and covid19
resilient or reckless we'll talk with dr
william shaffner when we come back
you're watching the law on crime trial
network
president trump is now back at the white
house after being hospitalized for four
days for treatment of
covet 19. he's already suggesting it
wasn't that bad
and telling people in a post that is no
worse than the flu
a post that facebook has now taken down
for spreading
disinformation here's some of what he
told the american people
upon his return don't
let it dominate you don't be
afraid of it you're going to beat it we
have the best
medical equipment we have the best
medicines all
developed recently and you're going to
beat it i went i didn't feel
so good and two days ago i could have
left two days ago two days ago i felt
great like better than i have in a long
time i said just recently
better than 20 years ago
and now we're joined by dr william
shaffner of vanderbilt university a
member of the panel that is looking at
the
clovid 19 vaccine and dr schaffner what
do you make of the president's treatment
of this
a deadly disease upon his dismissal from
the hospital
well brian it certainly sounds as though
the president is trivializing this
disease
which has killed over 200 000 americans
and untold numbers of people around the
world by now
this is a very serious infection
and we ought to take it seriously yes
a little bit of fear of this infection
would go a long way
you know we still don't have a national
strategy
to combat this infection we have a crazy
quilt of strategies depending on
what the governors and of the individual
states do
and you can see how effective that has
been this virus is still spreading over
most of the united states
in a largely unhindered fashion
so i would take actually a position
opposite
to that that you just heard namely
take this very seriously please
everybody
wear your mask do the social distancing
avoid large groups
and by the way influenza is coming soon
please get your flu vaccine
and just to be sure we hear it from you
clovid 19
is worse than the flu or is it not as
the president has suggested
oh we think covet is worse than the flu
we think it's more contagious and we
think its fatality rate
is higher look at it this way in a
really bad influenza season a couple or
three years ago
we had 80 000 deaths in the united
states
since february here in the united states
alone
we've had over 200 000 deaths you do the
arithmetic
i would think it's quite evident that
covet
is worse than flu and flu is plenty bad
dr schaffner a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
the president rightly so got vip
treatment at walter reed hospital
but what about for the covet patient who
goes to their local hospital what
treatment is available for them
well rhonda i actually think that the
average person
going to a reasonable sized hospital
can't be a small hospital
if they had serious covet enough to be
hospitalized of course
would get essentially the same treatment
as the president
with one exception you will remember
early in his illness
he received an experimental drug
this this cocktail of antibodies
that was designed to prevent progression
of the infection
that cocktail of antibodies those
monoclonal antibodies
are still in clinical trials we don't
know whether they work or not
the president received that under
compassionate use
that's a special category the fda has
everybody else would have
otherwise i think received largely
the care the president received so in
that sense
yes we have treatments available but
remember what benjamin franklin said
an ounce of prevention is worth a pound
of cure
we'd much prefer to prevent this
absolutely
it almost sounded brian as though the
president wanted us
all to get infected and treated and uh
deal with it almost bring it on
dr bring us up today on the latest in
the race for a vaccine and with the news
that the white house is now
trying to stop the fda guidelines on
testing and releasing the vaccine
well as we all know there are a number
of phase 3
clinical trials currently underway with
different vaccines
and we hope they all run to completion
the food and drug
administration has recently proposed
stiffer guidelines for safety and
efficacy of these vaccines and after
all of the information we have gotten
from the white house
saying there would be no political
influence in the release of a vaccine
here we have the fat fingers of the
white house
influencing these uh food and drug
administration regulations
golly that sounds like political
interference to me
that will lead to skepticism i take it
about the vaccine
oh absolutely i think the public may be
preoccupied with the patient uh with the
president's illness but this was seen
immediately
by the public health and the infectious
disease community and there was another
wave of skepticism that came out
it had been delayed by all of these firm
comments were going to rely on the
science
but now i think there's another wave of
skepticism
people are saying oh really my goodness
that looks pretty political to us
indeed it does dr william schaffner from
vanderbilt thank you again for joining
us
always fascinating insights and
important information actual information
from you
thank you doctor my pleasure thank you
brian
coming up this week's winners and losers
in the media covering
and covering up at the white house
you're watching the law and crime
trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors at meteorite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin
who's the editor-in-chief of mediaite
which like the law and crime trial
network
is part of the dan abrams media empire
and aiden you chose as your first winner
chris wallace for taking on a trump
campaign official about the protocol
followed or not followed by the first
family in his aides at the debate last
week
let's talk about reasonable risk because
there was the debate
on tuesday night as you say that i
moderated the the rules from the
cleveland clinic
could not have been more clear everyone
everyone in the audience was to wear a
mask
the president and the the vice former
vice president i
were the only ones exempt from that we
got a picture up on the screen
after the first family came in they all
took off their masks
so did the white house chief of staff
mark meadows
do they think that the health and safety
rules for everybody else do not apply to
them
so aiden chris wallace not afraid to
hammer a trump campaign official on fox
news
for sure now so chris wallace is the
anchor of fox news sunday
uh and he was quite frustrated uh in
this interview
i think partially because the white
house wasn't making any white house
officials
available for sunday show interviews uh
they had to deal so
sunday show hosts had to deal with
campaign surrogates like steve cortez
and jason miller to get updates on the
president's health
which is obviously not ideal now chris
wallace has asked this question before
about the first family
taking off their masks for the tuesday
debate now when the tuesday debate
happened that was before we knew that
the president
would test positive for the coronavirus
and the
first family was actually approached by
officials within the debate hall
and asked if they needed masks uh and
so because it was in congruency with the
rules that they wear mass throughout the
entire debate
and they declined now this is something
that chris wallace brought up on air on
fox news and has repeatedly asked
uh trump campaign officials he
repeatedly questioned steve cortez on it
in that interview
and didn't get any answer super cortez
kept dodging the question
and uh sort of moving on to different
topics related to masks but not
answering why the first family wouldn't
just comply
and wear masks throughout the debate
those were excellent questions and part
of your losers this week the white house
itself for trying to
cover up what was going on once the
president was sent to the hospital
here's an exchange with the white house
press corps grilling his doctor dr
sean conley outside walter reed
has he ever been on supplemental oxygen
he
right now he is not honest i know you
keep saying right now but should we read
into the fact that he had been preaching
yesterday and today he was not on oxygen
so he has not been on it during this his
covent treatment
he's not on oxygen right now
they really can't keep their story
straight because after he talked then
mark meadows behind the scenes was
giving more uh serious information more
about his condition that's right and
we should give huge props to the white
house press corps this weekend for
their questioning of dr sean conley and
the rest of the president's position
um this was a really staggering series
of press conference that we had from
these doctors
uh that clip that you just showed was
from saturday when sean conley was asked
if the president was ever administered
supplemental oxygen
he said that he was not on oxygen right
now sort of comically danced around
whether the president was ever on oxygen
ended up getting pressed to the point
where he said the president was not on
oxygen today
it was not on oxygen yesterday which was
friday at the subsequent press
conference on sunday
uh reporters questioned him again and he
revealed that the president actually was
given supplemental oxygen on friday
before he was airlifted
to walter reed um so he effectively
admitted that he had been misleading and
that he had lied to reporters
which was a really big moment and i
think struck a lot
of journalists as a problem with you
know these are the official doctors for
the president
that are supposed to be working for the
taxpayer and conveying information about
the president's health
uh to americans and they are misleading
on everything from the president being
administered to oxygen
to what was seen on his lungs when they
were scammed so it was a really
bad moment for the president's doctors
and it was also a bad moment for the
white house
when you had mark meadows going off and
giving an on background briefing to
reporters right after that press
conference
and saying that the president's vital
signs were actually really really bad
uh which directly contradicted uh the
kind of rosy assessment that dr sean
conley had delivered in that press
conference
so it was it was a really messy uh sort
of messy messaging all around from the
white house
uh and i still don't think they've done
a good job of clearing it up uh
even now that the president's been
released from the hospital
all right aidan mclaughlin thank you so
much for being here tonight and thank
you for all of you for
watching we'll be back here again next
week and thanks again to the team at law
and crime for getting us on the air
and off the air
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you